um
okay so hello everybody thanks for
coming um
i'm going to talk about um developing
and optimizing code in the warframe
compiler
um it's a kind of a follow-on a little
bit from tom's talk
um that he gave earlier i'll try and go
a little bit more
in in some lower level details and uh
give you some examples of
what we've been working on since the
last release so
this is just an overview of what the
warframe compiler looks like
i'm going to be mainly focusing on this
part the code generation
and the conversion to cpu instructions
um
so as you saw in tom's talk we we
convert
mathematica code to this warfram
intermediary representation or from ir
and then that in turn is converted to
the llvmir
and as tom mentioned already llvm itself
performs various optimizations
um and you can target a specific um
generated assembly code from that or
generate a library
and get machine code that you can run
from that
so in the type system in the compiler
there are like as
some i think already mentioned a much
wider set of machine
number types available than there are
mathematica itself
and it's actually much easier to develop
things in this structured environment
in the type system than it is to develop
them in the kernel
um we've also added support in this
version for numeric arrays in the in the
compiler that's
complete support for arithmetic and some
structural operations
as tom mentioned we also have a number
of
new data structures and a number of data
types strings and booleans etc
in this talk i'm going to be uh focusing
on arithmetic
so initially um all of the arithmetic
from both the compiler and the kernel
were done through a library
that we built up over time called
warframe rtl the runtime library
and it lived solely in this library as
we extended this library
and turned it into c plus and used
template arithmetic
so that we could support all the
additional types like
floats eight bit integers etc
the new thing uh for version 12.2 is
that all of the mathematical
functionality all of the scalar math
functions in the compiler are
implemented in the compiler itself and
that's um
one of testimony to to how fast the
compiler is
at least how fast the generated code is
as john mentioned already
there's still a problem with the actual
speed of the compilation
um the other thing is um that it allows
us
to generate to develop the compiler
framework itself by implementing parts
of the compiler in the compiler itself
we can generalize it and
add features that are missing um and the
third thing is that when when you call a
function from a library it's essentially
a black box
and you know nothing about it so you're
just calling an external function with
some parameters whereas the way that
llvm works
um it can do a lot of optimizations
um when it knows more about the actual
nitty gritty of what goes on
inside the function so i'll give you um
some examples that are a little bit
later so as i said it's a good test of
the compiler infrastructure
um we can then optimize the mapping to
llvm
and specific specify you know a specific
llvm intrinsics from the compiler
and and extend the compiler support by
adding some kind of c plus plus type
templated features
so why is it good to use llvm and what
sorts of things in llvm do
so in in the old compiler it essentially
translates
in in a fairly dumb way it's
function by function um exactly what
your program is doing
and it does no kind of modern compiler
kind of optimizations on that code
what llvm can do is once you have its
intermediary representation
you can do all sorts of transformations
to make the code more efficient so it
can do constant folding
it can look for patterns in code and try
to optimize them
it can do common sub expression
elimination
it can do transformations isomorphic
forms things like value numbering it can
switch loops
it can pull out invariant code from from
loops
so the sorts of patterns are uh you know
subtraction from zero it's just a number
subtraction from a number by itself with
um
the proviso that it's not a floating
point section here
that's just zero and twice a number by
itself
is just the number itself so these might
seem like trivial things but they
actually turn up quite commonly once you
start to
fold in and work on lots and lots of
code
and another thing um is value numbering
so that's kind of a generalization of a
common sub expression elimination so
here we've got
a simple multiplication an intermediary
assignment
and another multiplication but this
assignment here
is just of course it results in the same
multiplication as we have here but
because of the introduction of the
intermediary variable common sub
expression
elimination can't work to to reduce that
but um the so-called value numbering
optimization
can work and then this computation here
is eliminated
it's just um it's just reusing this
value so these are sorts of things that
llvm can do automatically for us that's
one of the reasons why we want to use it
so you saw you saw this in tom's talk i
can
thankfully skip through some of the
details i'm just defining a simple
function
in mathematica and this is just calling
bit length
and all i do when i want to compile it
is just
add a tight markup to say what kind of
type number
i'm interested in working with so this
is the definition of my function
and then i just call function compile on
it and it makes me
a compiled code function that works with
into 64 input
and gives me a into 64 output so this is
a machine integer on a 64-bit machine
now there's a lot of stuff going on here
and all you really see is the result of
what's going on so actually digging down
inside
um helps to kind of optimize the code so
let's look a little bit
um you saw an example of this in tom's
talk so if i just take that
bit length simple bit length function
and i look at the
warframe ir then it's marked up as this
and these are kind of
machine instructions that are going on
there's some some strange stuff with the
x4
there's one chord to count leading zeros
and there's another one to count leading
zeros
these are llvm instructions and then
there's a subtraction so i
i have the number of bits of my type say
63 if it's a signed integer
and i subtract off the number of leading
zeros and that's tells me how many bits
i have
and then the bit x or is something
needed if i have negative numbers
remember i specified here
that i'm working with signed integers
well signed integers could be positive
or negative
so there's some extra stuff going on
here that has to deal with when
numbers are negative in order to get the
right bit count
so the first thing when you're working
on code is that um
i think i mentioned already that types
that since the compiler works with types
it's a little bit different to working
on mathematical code well mathematically
you
write a one there is only one machine
integer and so that's pretty unambiguous
but in the compiler
when you have eight bit integers signed
and unsigned 16 bit signed and unsigned
you need to be a little bit careful
about how you write code
so in the compiler when you type a one
in your code it's interpreted to have
the default type of machine integer
and this is the default floating point
type is a machine wheel
and the default complex type is a
machine complex rule
so if i write something like this in my
function okay
then this one is a machine integer one
and i'm going to add a machine integer
one to a floating point number
and get a floating point number as a
result um
because of the way that llvm works it's
able to say oh
okay i know that this one is going to be
added to a floating point number and so
it's going to automatically
uh create a floating point number
without casting it
so i don't pay any runtime penalty llvm
is smart enough to optimize this and say
i know i'm going to be adding it to a
floating point number
i'm going to make this essentially a one
point here
but i need to be a little bit careful if
i'm going to be adding unsigned
integer 8 because this is now machine
integer 64-bit signed integer
i want to add it to an unsigned integer
the output for this
is going to be a machine integer so this
is going to be up promoted
to uh the machine integer type which may
not be what i want so i need to be a
little bit careful
so if i really want to be specific about
it i have to tell the compiler
um that this is excuse me this should be
a one here
that this one that i'm introducing here
really should be
an unsigned eight integer type okay so
that maintains the type
information in this sum here and i'm
adding an unsigned integer eight to an
unsigned integer eight and getting an
unsigned integer
out and we have some kind of um
simple helper functions that will just
say give me a the number one
which is the same type as x here and
that just
uh avoids you having to retype the name
of the type here
that changes to unsigned into 16 then
this is
going to be an unsigned integer 16
so it's good to write your code a little
bit in this way
rather than this way to avoid any kind
of type ambiguity
now a numeric array arithmetic is fully
supported in the compiler um
at the moment it still goes through the
runtime library so even though the
scalar arithmetic is completely in the
compiler now the array arithmetic is
still
in warframe rtl but it does work and you
can do
all sorts of arithmetic now with uh
different number types
here so here i've got a adding two
arrays or two vectors of integer eight
type
and i'm doing some computation on them
and this is the result
and i can mix and match them so i have
an integer 8 and i'm adding it to a
float
type and it's smart enough to know about
the coercion rules and things like that
and produce
is a result of of the appropriate type
now of course when i mix types in this
way
um i i'm i'm gonna do some type
promotional type coercion
generally um so it's more efficient
if you really work with not with arrays
of the same type you will avoid making a
copy of something
and having to cast it so it's it's a
good idea to work with numbers and
arrays of the same type
and also if you work on number theory
type of computations
like i showed you with the uh the bit
length function
it's a good idea to work with unsigned
integers rather than signed
integers because it kind of gets a
little bit um bit shifting of negative
integers etc
is a little bit undefined in c and so we
have to do some
you know two's complement representation
and that sort of thing
if we know that we're working with an
unsigned integer then that's just a
native bit shift it can compile down to
a native bit shift and work more
efficiently
so here's a little example here so the
first thing to do when you work on your
code
is to time it so all this does
is just makes a function called subtract
and compiles that
and the second function here is going to
call repeated timing but it's going to
call it inside the compiler so repeated
timing is a kernel function
and you can call it on any code but
repeated timing is also implemented
natively in the compiler
and if you want to time fine in a
fine-grained way
your compiler code it's a good idea to
not call
repeated timing outside of the function
and get the function
overhaul call overhead it's a good idea
to call it inside the function
and it really does measure the speed
that your
your assembly code is um is executing so
here are three examples
this is calling the kernel function
subtract here with repeat of the kernel
function repeated timing
this is calling the compiled function
subtract with the kernel function
repeated timing
and this is doing the compiled function
subtract with repeated timing inside the
compiler
and you'll see that the time measurement
here is quite a bit faster it really is
measuring the speed of executed subtract
inside the compiler
rather than the overhead of going
through the evaluator and calling the
the kernel code so this is really
showing me the actual speed of
subtraction in the compiler
rather than the uh the function called
overhead that's
um that's going through the kernel and
here's an example with uh gcd
so there are several layers to the way
that we've built up arithmetic so we've
implemented something like 150 functions
the
compiler now the warframe compiler now
has more functionality than the old
compiler with respect to arithmetic
and it's built up in layers as tom
mentioned already
when you do arithmetic in mathematica
and when it overflows the arithmetic
it switches to big numbers or it does
other things and
the cost of checking whether an error
goes on can be quite significant
and there's no way to switch that off in
mathematica whenever you try it one plus
one
it knows nothing about the fact that uh
the number's not going to overflow
so it needs to use a integer edition uh
that actually checks for overflow which
is slower than the
integer edition that's available in a
native cpu instruction
so we have in the compiler we have
several ways of of controlling these
things we can say do i want to do
checked arithmetic or unchecked
arithmetic and then we build up our
functions using intermediary levels that
can be used
and then we actually call native native
functions from llvm or from the c
math library i think tom gave you an
example of to see math library in his
talk
so let's take one one example here i'm
going to call the the function the
exponential function
a floating a float version not not a
double version um
and then this is going to get compiled
down using the warframe compiler
and here i'm going to say well i'm going
to natively call
the c math library function from within
the compiler
and let's just just compare the two so
what happens when i call this
by default the warframe compiler is
going to call the native
c math exponential function but it's
also going to add a test if
overflows happened or not so it's got
some additional stuff going on here
um and and this shows the two things
together so this is just shows that
they give the same values this shows
that when i call the wolfram
compiler default exponential function um
here it's uh it's checked for an
overflow
it's issued a message and then switched
to kernel arithmetic
whereas this one hasn't it's just given
me the ieee infinity that comes out of
here so you need to be a little bit
careful
if you switch off um the error checking
from the warframe compiler you can get
exceptions coming out of your code
so another bit about llvm so when you're
writing your code
um one thing that we found is we've
tried to optimize
code in different ways and sometimes
it makes no difference whatsoever so
here's one example from llvm
you might think oh i'll try and uh
optimize my code here
here i'm just calling the native
function and i'm multiplying something
by two
and lrbn is actually turning this into a
left shift
left shift by one okay um
and all of these these things are our
equivalent computation so i do x
plus x or or i shift x left
by one or i multiply by two and they all
combine
down to the same thing so if you think
you're rewriting your code and
optimizing it and you're not seeing much
of a difference you can dig down into
the ir
and actually have a look and see what uh
what instructions it's being
converted to so let's actually get to a
couple of
applications of of the warframe compiler
uh
what i'm going to do here is just write
a very simple program that's going to
compute a determinant here
i'm just going to multiply uh two of the
values
multiply the other two and subtract them
um
the only trick here is that i'm going to
do this in an unchecked block so this
this multiplication of subtraction is
really going to be using
the uh the negative instructions for
subtraction
and compilation and i'm going to write a
little wrapper function here
called test overflow overflow test
here and i'm going to wrap that outside
and i can do this function now natively
in the wolfram compiler
and when i'm completely done then i can
go and see if it got
an overflow or not that prevents the
example that we had before with the
exponential function
leaking out into the kernel these ieee
infinities or whatever
okay and um now it turns out that this
is not a very good way to compute the
determinant
there is an alternative way and this
shows something new in the compiler
so an alternative method that's due to
kahan is actually to use a fused
multiply add
operation or several of them and it
works like this
so so you compute an initial product
here
this initial product this initial
product then gets truncated
to a floating point number so it's
53-bit number by 53-bit number
the product is 106 bits and it gets
truncated down
to 53 bits so there is an error here in
this product
okay what i'm going to do is use the
fuse multiply add
i'm going to feed it back uh these
numbers that i started with
but with a negative value and i'm going
to add it to this truncated product that
i have here
so essentially what this going to do
here is it's going to tell me which of
the 53 bits were thrown away
and it's going to put that into a floaty
point number and store is the error
then i'm going to use another floating
point uh fuse multiply add to add in the
other bit of the determinant here to the
bit that i've computed i've completed
this bit i'm going to add
that this product and subtract this this
away i'm going to get a final result and
i'm going to add in the error
from this product that i've i've
computed with this whose multiply add
so let's take a look at that um here
with this particular example so i'm
going to take these particular values
for my matrix i'm going to use a
numerical approximation to pi
and to e and i'm going to use these
rational numbers
for my other entries and these rational
numbers actually come from the continued
fraction
approximation to pi and e so you can see
where they come from here
this is a an approximation that's close
to pi
and this is an approximation that's
close to e
now if i use my naive determinant
computation this is the result i get
here and if i use this extended fused
multiply method that feeds back the
error then i get this
result here and you can see that the two
results are the same
for the first eight digits and they
differ in the last eight digits
so what i can do is i in mathematica i
can analyze this
obviously using arbitrary precision
arithmetic so that's what i'm going to
do here
we don't have fused multiply add
arithmetic so i'm just going to use the
naive method
but with higher precision 32 bits of
precision
and this is the result that i get and
you can see that the fused multiply add
method
has got a completely accurate result
through all the bits whereas about half
of the digits of the naive method were
incorrect
and the error in this method of fused
multiply method is
has actually been proved to be correct
too in the worst case
uh three over two alps so the last thing
uh for this example is to say well how
did that compare performance-wise i'm
doing this extra work i'm using these
multiply add operations i'm doing an
extra product
um let's see um
kind of a performance profile of the
compiler of these things implemented in
the compiler so these are my methods
this is the naive method implemented
completely in unchecked arithmetic
okay so i'm just switching off any kind
of overflow
checking and this is the fused multiply
method and you see that they're really
really
are very close in speed so this extra
product that i was computing
uh was was not really um
affecting performance very much at all
and this is the code that i showed you
where i had an additional
wrapper function that did an overflow
test uh
right at the very end that didn't
interfere with the intermediary
computations of the determinant
but adjusted a final floating point
overflow test
and that doesn't affect the performance
very much at all what is not so good
is the way that mathematica does it does
a um
it does a floating point multiply and
then it fully point error test
it does another floating point multiply
another float with two point error
then it does a subtraction and it does
another floating point error test
and all of these can cause cpu resource
exhaustion and also branch prediction
problems and you see that
even when this is implemented inside the
compiler that generates very efficient
code
it's quite a bit slower to fully check
every floating point arithmetic
operation for a floating point error so
we get something like a factor of four
here
so that's one performance tier but that
is to to do a lot of your arithmetic by
switching off the overflow checking and
write some
kind of high level function that's going
to go and analyze the result
and and check it
so the next example that i'm going to
show you is a comparison of
inter integer arithmetic the greatest
common divider so the
the most commonly known method to
compute the
greatest common divide is due to euclid
so essentially you take two numbers
and you find the remainder of division
and you take the smaller of the two
input numbers
and you use that and you take the
remainder of the division of the two
numbers and you use that and you
continually
compute the gcd in a recursive way
there's another algorithm
that uses only binary operations so the
problem here is that this
is essentially doing integer division
which can be quite expensive
there's another algorithm first
published in
the late 60s um that essentially does
only subtractions and bit shifting
so it tries to reduce everything to odd
numbers then subtracting odd numbers
gives an even number
then it will shift out the zeros in that
even number
get another odd number and then continue
that kind of kind of evaluation
now std uh gcd which is what we had
in some earlier versions of mathematica
because the wolf ram
rtl was written in c plus plus uh uses a
a a version of the
the euclid gcd uh what i'm going to show
you here is that the compiler
implementation of this
is just as fast as the c plus plus code
was from
std gcd and i'm going to show you that
the compiler implementation of this
is is even faster and i'll try to
explain a little bit why that's the case
so three things i'm going to do i'm
going to use a loop instead of recursion
i'm going to use unchecked arithmetic
now this is unchecked
integer arithmetic not not floating
point arithmetic
that means that i don't check that
integers wrap around
because i know that every step in the
gcd is a reduction of integers there's
never going to be a case
where i subtract two things and i get
something larger
or shift something down and get
something larger
and the other thing that i'm going to do
is a bit like tom showed why
disabling interrupts in function compile
i'm going to use a lower level primitive
to disable it locally in this function
so here's my gcd function
for euclid it just says swap the two
if one is greater than the other and it
just does a while loop
uh testing when it when something
becomes zero and just returns the value
and this is the remainder step and then
this is swapping
the smaller value to the first value and
taking the remainder which is always
smaller
as the second value and it just loops
around here
okay so this is really mathematical code
with a little bit of compiler uh syntax
and some markup uh for efficiency
and then the type marker that we have
let's skip this thing uh let's go
to the binary gcd code
okay so this is my code for binary dc
it's a little bit more complicated
you can essentially ignore this stuff
it's pre-processing
um by removing common powers of two
the essentially the essentially
important stuff is down here
um what i'm doing is while the numbers
are different
i'm going to see which one of the two is
greater
subtract it from the other one then i'm
going to call this llvm
specific function that's going to remove
or tell me how many trailing zeros does
this number have
i know at this step that it must be even
because i'm subtracting two odd numbers
so i'm going to say well you know how
much is it even how many zeros
does it have is it four is it uh
you know eight or whatever and then what
i'm going to do is
is take that number of zeros and shift
them out of the number
and create a new number um that's odd
again
and just continue around this loop until
i'm done
okay now generally this is doing a lot
more cycles
um than the euclidean algorithm but
here's a comparison of the two
implementations
so this is the binary method this is the
euclidean method and here's another one
that we just implemented for
completeness that cause
interleaves the euclid step and the
binary step
this is a particular set of inputs that
gives the worst case that the euclid's
algorithm
what happens here is that every single
division is going to have a quotient of
one so it's the slowest convergent
pair of values for for the euclid uh
algorithm so this is the worst case in a
sense the worst case
timing of the euclidean gcd method and
you see that the binary gcd method
is more than an order of magnitude
faster
and on the other hand this is the worst
pair of values for the binary method
because what happens here is every time
i subtract numbers
i make an even number but that's only
got one zero bit
in it so i'm only knocking off one bit
at a time as i go through
the algorithm and here you can see that
the binary method
is actually slightly slower than the
euclidean method
and then if i take random inputs um
randomly generated inputs and these are
according to the distribution theory of
um
of of random numbers this is what i
would expect in the euclidean uh
algorithm these would be the quotients
that i would expect
i'd expect a quotient of 140 percent of
the time
question of two 17 of the time
these random numbers were generated from
this distribution
then again i see that on the average
case these random
average generated numbers that the
binary method is quite a bit faster than
the euclid method
like a factor of six and the other
important thing is that the binary
method is really quite robust i mean
it's
you throw any pair of numbers at it with
good or bad properties
and it has a pretty good nice stable
timing
so the other thing that we saw here is
that when we implemented this
in the runtime library in c plus plus
and we implemented it in the compiler
exactly the same algorithm with exactly
the same primitives
we saw that the compiler was actually
generating faster code
uh like 30 faster code and we couldn't
quite
figure out why for a little bit of time
and and the reason for that
is that as tom said um when you call
function compile
it works in memory and it's able to use
cpu instructions that are native to your
processor
but when you build a library especially
from rtl and mathematica
they're built for a generic x86
processor and they can't use
optimized instructions from from you
know more modern processors like haswell
or whatever
and so this just shows that this shows
that if i
if i take a function compile of my my
gcd function
and then uh here i export it and load it
back in as a library so this is actually
making a physical
file that's using different optimization
settings to
to function compile then i can see that
it is about 30
slower this is making a generic library
so i can share with other people
to be fair now i could of course make a
library that's specific to my platform
and i could bring i could bring this
down
but then if somebody's got a like an
older cpu i wouldn't be able to share
that with them
so so that would be a problem
um and this is the last thing um now i'm
not
not expecting users to go down to this
level
necessarily but just to show you that
it's the sort of thing that you can do
if you want to and that is
um to actually go and use tools and you
can take code from the warfarm compiler
and you can put it into some third-party
tools
uh let me just show you uh so this is
one example here
um where we've taken uh
code generated this is our gcd code
generated from the warframe compiler the
llvm code that's been generated
i just pasted it into this compiler
explorer and it will generate for me
according to what cpu parameters i've
put in it will generate for me the
machine code
and what i can see here is this uh this
particular instruction is the one that
i'm interested in
because of the parameters that i've used
here i said use all of the modern cpu
architecture optimizations and i see
this
tz cnt instruction here that corresponds
to my
llvm count trailing zero function in my
binary
code and that's a specific instruction
that's available only in uh intel
haswell and
later processes okay so so i can use the
compiler and i can generate
you know a highly specific targeted
machine code
and the last thing that i can do if i if
i do like i said
um if i generate um
two versions of code and i want to
compare them um
i cannot just time them but i could
actually put them into something like
this third party
thing here here on the left is my
determinant code the naive one which
just does
you know the product the product and the
subtraction
here is the uh assembler code that's
been generated
and here is an actual performance
profile that comes from this
lvm mca machine code analyzer
and it tells me if i do 100 iterations
of this code this is how many
cpu instructions i'm using this is the
total number of cycles
uh cpu cycles that i've made and then
there's a whole bunch of stuff about
latency
and all sorts of stuff in the processor
that's telling me
you know um how these register being
used and what kind of the the delays of
the operations are
and and the similar thing here here's
the um
the code generated from the wolfram
compiler at the l or the m code
that's uh using the fused multiply add
method
um and here's the same thing here for
this
used multiply add and what you can
notice is if you remember the timings
were very similar when i switched off
the checked arithmetic
it's a fraction of uh you know 1.08
seconds 1.13 seconds something like that
and you can actually see why here that
this fused multiply add even though it's
doing an extra multiplication
uh some of the register usage and stuff
is more optimized and so
it's only using 1200 cpu instructions
whereas
this is using 1100 and that's only a
difference of like you know
less than 10 or something like that so
it kind of bears out the timings that we
got when
when we used repeated timing to uh to
test them so
um so that's the last thing i wanted to
mention um
so in conclusion so um
all of the native um mathematical
arithmetic
is now built into the warfarin compiler
something like 150 functions
it was a lot of meticulous work to build
it all in there
but it's definitely worth it llvm can do
a good job of
optimizing that we can generate much
faster code
we don't need to call external libraries
to do arithmetic now there's no function
calls
also llvm can do a lot more
optimizations on the code
and and analyze the code a lot better
and produce
much better machine code as a result um
there's no more guesswork for code
optimization if the compiler was calling
warfare mrtl
essentially that's a black box to the
user
um and the user has no idea what
algorithm that's using
uh and
we have nothing to hide about the
implementation we're very proud of it so
now all of the code for the arithmetic
is written in mathematical itself you
saw it slightly stylized mathematica
um but uh you can use that as a starting
point
for your code or you can take bits and
pieces of it
with ideas of things that you want for
your own functions and
you can you can use those in your own
code or you can use
intermediary utility functions to call
them in your own code
so it's a completely open and
transparent workflow
the idea is to start with the warfarm
language code mark it up with the type
then use some kind of stylized
extensions maybe think about aborts or
check to
unchecked arithmetic you can use the
existing
code base as a starting point um
uh so so that's the state of this
version for the next version
um we'll be working on array operations
and building those in natively so they
they still call
a lot of the numeric array operations uh
for arithmetic still called the warframe
rtl
so the next version will be working on
moving those all natively into the
compiler
and then linear algebra and
lots more i've never stopped so um
okay that's um that's everything so i
hope that was uh
a really long ah thank you
oh yeah uh if anyone's still listening
so uh we do have um
a question and answer session um in
about
uh half an hour i believe uh with tommy
jones on the compiler so if there are
any questions that anyone has
we're happy to answer them
thanks again